I mean let's be honest that was an epic
skid so the New Year's special for
Doctor Who and yes I did get my new
sonic screwdriver at Christmas as I
normally do apologies for this being a
day later than I'd planned I had some
technical difficulties but it also gives
me the chance to kind of throw out a
really humongous thank you and note of
appreciation because you know I at the
very end of 2018 I kind of put out a
little bit of a stronger call to action
in terms of the patreon and the hope
that of pushing things in a direction
where maybe I can start to at least get
this on the trajectory where this is
what I do and you guys have like stepped
up to a degree that I did not think was
reasonable to expect and and while this
is it's still a ways before this could
be my living like the the leap and the
faith that you guys showed me and in you
know committing to that whether it was
at a one dollar level or whatever you
ended up doing that I'm legit touched
alright enough about me let's get to the
doctor so yeah hmm resolution so then
this is where the proper series finale
was hiding like hey I liked this to the
point that I'm a little bit annoyed I'm
like dude chip know where you just were
you like just holding you're better
writing instincts in reserve and letting
everyone else shine during the actual
series like what the heck so while this
is by no means an amazing episode and
like our best thing ever
I think it
I mean if I were to lump it I know
technically it's the first-ever New
Year's special which I'm fine with as a
premise but like if I were to stack it
up against the Christmas specials easily
top three like it's right up there again
to be fair I tend to not like a lot of
the Christmas specials all that much but
I thought this was quite good and it
didn't have a lot of the niggling
problems I tend to have with even chip
Mills better episodes cuz like you know
I enjoyed the ghost monument but like
there were things that bugged me there
wasn't really much that bugged me here
this was this was good yeah okay so
where do where do we start with it well
first of all spoilers like I'm not even
gonna not even gonna front
I enjoyed it if you haven't seen it by
now I don't know what to tell you
so yeah Dalek I think that was a really
this this was a really good way to
reintroduce the Daleks because we
haven't had them for a bit I mean we we
have technically had them every series
prior to series 11 at least in a one-off
scene you know series 10 had that weird
little tiny divergence with bill and and
the doctor running into them ever so
briefly but we have an eye it doesn't
feel like we've had a proper Dalek story
in a while honestly I would say probably
sense into the Dalek because Magician's
apprentice and which is familiar was
more of a Davros story than a Dalek
story I do distinguish between those two
so this was really good and I I think it
did what was the best way to kind of
reestablish what the Daleks are and how
why they're scary because let's let us
not forget that this series for a
variety of reasons between the new
timeslot new doctor all this other stuff
has a hole has brought in a whole new
law a bunch of people watching it who
may or may not have been watching it
previously so I think totally valid to
basically rheostat
the Dalek basically from scratch and I
mean it is very obviously sort of taking
a cue from the episode Dalek from series
1 in terms of look we're just going to
give you one and go this is why you
should be afraid and while I can't say
that this is completely original for
choosing to do that approach it was
absolutely the best idea to do because
that like I don't I don't feel like the
Daleks have been properly threatening
for a while but this one is and there's
a number of things about it first of all
I initially want to start them like this
Dalek isn't behaving like a normal Dalek
and I found myself going I hope that
they explained that but like don't bog
us down an explanation and they
explained you to the exact sort of way I
like those sorts of things explained
which is we get a line that accounts for
it but we don't stop the story in order
to cover all this just recon scout cool
awesome
like honestly for me at least that's
enough and it fits it because when this
sort of thing gets introduced for a very
long established you know piece of lore
like the Daleks you run the risk of it
feeling like wait what and feeling like
really retcon ii but for me it fits and
it makes sense because we've seen enough
about the Daleks over the years both in
new WHO and classic who to know that
there are sort of different castes and
different you know placements and roles
for the Daleks within the Dalek society
I mean we've seen you know the the
supreme Daleks and the the special
weapons Dalek and the cult of Skaro we
know that they will specialize in some
cases so by distinguishing this is a
specialized kind of Dalek that to me was
enough to roll with the things we see
him do that we've not seen them do
before and I also do like the things
that we see him do like the fact that he
treats this woman like a vehicle I think
he actually says like I am your pilot
I'm like okay that's a little unsettling
because of like how immediately
dehumanizing that is and obviously he
has no you know no use for her aside
from whatever practical function he can
get from her but like just hearing it
said that way it's like that's a little
chilling yeah and you know hearing the
voice was really cool I liked the look
of sort of the thrown together tank you
know which look you know was very much
looking like a doll like but at the same
time had it had a cobble together field
not similar from the from the doctor saw
me screwdriver
interestingly enough and sort of another
thing that I liked about that is
initially I was a little bit
disappointed when it showed up in the
tank I'm like oh but it was way more
interesting when it was you know outside
of it and kind of doing all this new
stuff but then they had the tank go up
against the military and I was like oh
we're reestablishing how deadly this is
and that was a really well shot sequence
because again we've seen Daleks kill a
lot of people you know over the years
but this felt like a really good
emphasis of just what these things are
capable of doing and again really good
job of establishing how just one is
really really bad news so all that was
really good and I enjoyed I enjoyed that
you know top to bottom as far as the
doctor goes I mean like I'm gonna be
more partial to Jody now than I was
through basically the entirety of series
11 and to reiterate I've never disliked
her but I didn't quite it wasn't
clicking yet until the very end of the
episode 10 of series 11 and you know
here now that I'm kind of already on
board with her I found myself and like
enjoying her right off the bat a lot
more and I I really am I am enjoying her
at this point I like a little moment I
like her getting I like her sort of
dipping into a bit more of the doctors
past because while I certainly do
appreciate that this doctor doesn't like
seem to already know everything
doesn't seem to have already met
everybody the it's nice to see her run
into more of a oh I know what you are
I've got history with you and it's nice
to see her play into that because it
does bring out something a little bit a
little bit different out of her
performance that we haven't had in the
other episodes that she's done up to
this point the other companions
obviously are Ryan kind of gets the big
focus Graham gets a few moments and yes
is also there as has kind of been the
case
I liked the the the archaeological
couple I actually I found myself getting
because they were so cute and kind of
endearing it made me initially nervous
in like a good way because I was like oh
one or both of them's gonna die and
they're cute and I kind of liked them
and and you know kind of played against
that cuz they actually pull through and
that was nice that was a nice change of
pace I think what else there is to say
oh the touch on eunuch I kind of got a
kick out of that like that the doctor
goes to unit which in which the doctor
eyes are really done in modern era the
doctor has encountered unit and unit has
looked for the doctor but the one time
the doctor goes to them and yeah they're
kind of big kind of don't exist at the
moment which on the grand scheme I'm
kind of okay with as well because I like
the doctor flying by the seat of her
pants and not having this massive
support network you know outside of the
companions but I like that it's it was
dismantled because of funding because
that also leaves the door open for that
issue getting resolved and unit coming
back so it didn't feel like writing out
you and be like n they are gone forever
it was more like like no this is why we
don't have them around right now I'm
like okay cool I can roll with that and
like and that's and that kind of feeds
into sort of what I said about
Chipping overall when I did my my series
overview which is that a lot of the
broad-stroke ideas i've liked and it
came down to a lot of the individual
episode writing that i didn't like
whereas here finally the broad ideas i
like and also the actual episode writing
is also solid which is nice i do want to
touch on briefly Ryan's dad because it's
something I'm kind of mixed feelings
about and it's one of those things that
I don't think there's anything actually
wrong with what's presented but I've got
my own sort of baggage that makes me not
enjoy it
the way it's meant to be enjoyed and to
put it as simply as I can I don't I have
a distaste for the narrative simplicity
that is very common in both television
and film where someone who has basically
a very very very long history of
screwing up or of having done something
really bad and then just left it for
years and years and years and years and
not done anything about that
getting forgiven and redeemed on the
back of as you know a single big gesture
and to be fair that's not entirely what
this episode is doing but there was
something about Ryan saying I forgive
you in in that moment that rang really
hollow to me because I don't think Ryan
would have said that under any of the
circumstances and I don't think it's
just because he was too better to say
what he felt I think he genuinely was
not ready to forgive him and the only
reason he did is because he thought he
was gonna die and the fact that that
kind of gets played for
like the genuine article that kind of
bothers me and I was worried about this
character from the get-go because there
was a line he had when they're in the
coffee shop and he says what do you want
me to say whatever it is I'll say it and
Ryan's response to that was pretty good
but the incident his dad said that I'm
like because it it just shows such a
fundamental misunderstanding of the
damage that you've done when you think
that there's some magic phrase or some
single gesture that you can do that's
gonna make it okay it's like no you need
to be prepared to spend as long as much
time as you spent getting it wrong you
need to be prepared to have to spend
that much time continuously doing it
right before you really have any
business asking or even implying
forgiveness you know a desire for
forgiveness and the tendency in
narratives to you know have it be big
gestures big speeches the right words
extenuating circumstances granting
people forgiveness is something that I
just I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say can
ever work and that it's never justified
it's just something that I see a lot and
doesn't sit right with me and this is
far from the most egregious example of
this kind of thing but it is a thing
that happens a lot and it doesn't sit
right with me
so but honestly that again I'm not even
gonna call that a fault of the episode
it's just something that doesn't work
for me given my history my baggage
because you know and it probably I would
be shocked if it bugs other people the
way it bugs me all that much because you
know other people have their own
approaches nobody else has got my
baggage that's fine so um yeah so I
think I'll run up there that was my big
kind of nitpick but this was
solid it was really good and it was kind
of reassuring as well because while I
think I had a certainly more nice things
to say about series 11 then some people
did I didn't love series 11 and I it was
reassuring to see not only I feel a
genuinely good episode really good
episode but the one that was written by
the showrunner that that is a little bit
reassuring now the big thing for
Chibnall with me with future episodes is
gonna be you know consistency but I will
say that having this be the last thing
that I see until God son of a 2020
before we get more episodes I feel more
comfortable with this being the last
thing I see prior to this then battle of
rich the Dibby Dibby so yeah I enjoyed
this Doctor Who resolution what did you
think about it whatever you thought drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff you
can do because there's buttons and links
including one to the patreon which you
know you guys are blowing me away and I
absolutely appreciate it in every little
bit helps
but there's other links you can check
out besides if you want to do that if
you don't want to click on any of them
you know what that's okay too cuz end of
the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]